et maintenant gaspard proust pour elle
est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bientôt noël oui dans les maisons les
familles se sont retrouvées dans la
cheminée le feu crépite et sous le sapin
des cadeaux les uns plus gros que les
autres se disputent la faveur des
enfants les yeux des parents sont
remplis de larmes à la vue de ce bonheur
idéal 2012 ce fut une année face les
salaires ont augmenté les employeurs
sont obligés d'envoyer des cv aux
salariés d'entreprises concurrentes et
le prix du mètre carré n'a jamais été
aussi proche de celui de la motte de
beurre
oui voilà ce qui se passe à peu près à
cette heure dans n'importe quelle
famille qatari
[Applaudissements]
alors je précise le qatar tout le monde
voit ce pays c'est le mali avec des bols
géologique
en france évidemment les choses sont
moins roses car ce fut une année étrange
enfin jusqu'au 7 mai y avait un truc et
puis soudain la panne de courant le
black out on a vu une f1 à rentrer aux
stands et en sortir un vélib
oui jusqu'au 7 mai 2012 la france
ressemblait un épileptique coq et depuis
on l'a droit paraplégique sous morphine
alors que retenir de cette année 2012
bas à 2012 une année moderne après avoir
cartonné dans tous les pays du monde
enfin le socialisme débarque en france
alors première mesure le gouvernement
décide de baisser les salaires ça c'est
faut comprendre la seule manière
d'assumer un poste pour lequel on n'est
pas compétent c'est de se rassurer en se
disant qu'on est mal payé
ah bah oui c'est le dialogue mais vous
êtes nuls ouais mais on n'est pas cher
pour ceux qui en doutaient oui le
changement c'est vraiment maintenant
2012 qui fut bon l'année du choc fiscal
enfin du choc de l'avc quoi c'est plus
un choc pour moi j'aimerais quand même
défendre un peu ce gouvernement reproche
à la gauche de ne pas faire grand chose
un peu d'honnêteté est quand même le
seul gouvernement qui donne envie à un
riche d'aller vivre en belgique
par dany boon et francis heaulme ce
qu'ils aimeraient vivre six mois par an
coincé entre londres et bruxelles fin
juillet et ne boudons pas notre plaisir
pour une fois qu'un gouvernement de
gauche arrivent à expulser des gens qui
payent leurs charter tout seul
[Applaudissements]
passons au fond à l'exil fiscal ça
concerne qui ça concerne les riches qui
ne sont pas sûrs d'avoir les capacités
de le rester mais les riches qui partent
c'est aussi des pauvres qui arrive un
bernard arnault en belgique duflot dans
un ministère
alors cécile duflot tout le monde voit
the voice
la maîtresse de cp avec un orgasme qui
lui restait coincé dans les cordes
vocales
[Applaudissements]
mais non je suis patiente chez c'est
juste que j'ai pas encore atterri
moi ça m'excite très près c'est un peu
le meilleur des deux mondes quoi une
cougar avec une voix d'ado fin
mai le retour de la gauche c'est aussi
l'égalité hommes-femmes qui progresse et
oui désormais en moselle des ouvriers se
battre pour des hauts fourneaux
c'est aussi les droits qu'ils avancent
bientôt les homosexuels qui pourront se
marier qui pourront adopter à ce rythme
là dans un an ils demanderont droit de
faire l'amour aux femmes
alors la droite qui très bêtement et et
contre quoi au lieu d'être un peu
perfide en proposant un amendement le
mariage pour tous ok mais avec le
divorce pour personne
là on verrait c'est encore foule dans
les mairies comme je vais bien voir ça
bref 2012 c'est aussi l'ascenseur social
pour certains
nafissatou qui désormais dans les
palaces hésitera à deux fois avant
d'ouvrir la porte de sa douche à
l'arrivée d'un homme de ménage
[Applaudissements]
nafissatou qui a la vertu de rassurer au
moins une personne dans le monde le
plombier polonais c'est à dire au prix
où elle pratique la pipe qui risque
d'être compétitif encore longtemps
mais 2012 c'est aussi l'année de la
déchirure entre les électeurs de droite
et de gauche c'est évident fin et un
récent sondage là il paraît que les
électrices de gauche pratique plus
souvent la fellation que les électrices
de droite ça ça c'est normal c'est
selena n'a de droite et une éducation
ils ont une politesse raconte pas leur
vie sexuelle un connard de la sofres
mais 2012 c'est aussi l'année de la
corse ce lac ans lille débutent et 20
morts cette année avec un constat quand
même quand on lit la liste des victimes
en corse c'est pas encore ça la parité
hommes femmes
[Musique]
[Rires]
bon faut relativiser je dirais encore ce
vingt morts par an c'est une catastrophe
en syrie 20 morts par jour sur une
accalmie
replaçons les choses dans leur contexte
alors certes cette année la syrie n'aura
pas vraiment contribué à la paix dans le
monde mais quelle prise de rendez vous
pour les jeux paralympiques
[Applaudissements]
2012 c'est aussi une année sombre pour
la biodiversité on a perdu eva joly et
avec elle cet inimitable accent du
sud-ouest norvégien
quand il va pas rendre quelque part dans
le monde un meuble ikea s'écroule
2012 l'année sport finale de l'euro de
foot l'espagne bat l'italie s'écoule un
milliard de téléspectateurs
pour une fois qu'un conflit entre deux
pays du tiers-monde passionne les foules
2012 c'est aussi l'année des révélations
l'homme politique manuel valls mannequin
téléshopping arnaud montebourg
théologie à n'engager véronique genest
que dire d'autre l'année des ressources
naturelles cette année en france on l'a
découvert un gisement à soupçonner le
réservoir de voix du front national
front national c'est un peu les gaz de
schiste de la droite s'est
fracturé c'est dur mais ça peut servir
cet électorat du front national qui aura
tant fait rêver mais bon moi je veux pas
stigmatiser l'électorat du front
national c'est un électorat très très
créatif puisqu'il est capable d'être
xénophobe tout en habitant la cambrousse
profonde c'est à dire un lieu où on
croise un clandestin que lorsqu'il tombe
d'un train d'atterrissage mal fermée
2012 année des catastrophes on peut pas
en parler mohamed merah toulouse qui
pointe les dysfonctionnements de la
police c'est vrai quand tu écoutes les
enregistrements entre la police et
mohamed la seule information utile et en
tirer c'est que ce n'est pas leur aide
qu'on aurait dû lui envoyer mais un prof
de français
et y at il eu quand même des bonnes
nouvelles en cette année oui oui il ya
une bonne nouvelle le naufrage du costa
concordia
pour une fois que ce ne sont pas des
clandestins qui se noient au large d'une
île italienne
alors ta belle très belle
les corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux